Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Méris. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt und möchte Ihnen das
Aufnahmen gespürt. Bevor ich damit beginnen brauche, um Ihre persönliche Information,
sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, natürlich. Klar. Ja, wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße
Hannah Müller. Könnten Sie mit Ihrem Vornamen bestabieren?
Hannah HAAAA. Okay, Frau Müller. Wie alt sind Sie? Müller, bitte Müller, mit Ö, O,
umlaut. Nicht U, umlaut. Müller. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 42. Und wann wurden Sie
genau geboren? Am 20.07.83. 83. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,69. 1,69.
1,69. Und wie viel wegen Sie? Ja, ich wiege so 68 Kilo. Können Sie wiederholen, bitte?
68 Kilo. Lasst uns über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, Frau Müller. Wie kann ich Ihnen
sagen? Ja, ich habe solche heftigen Schmerzen im Bauch und zwar im Oberbauch. Und es strahlt
auch richtig heftig aus. Und ja, so richtig angefangen hat es eigentlich gestern Abend nach
dem Abendessen. Und ja, da haben wir ein bisschen fett gegessen, gebe ich ja zu. Ja. Und dann
in der Nacht fing das an und ich habe, also die ganze Nacht habe ich das Gefühl nicht
geschlafen, weil ich mit einmal solche Schmerzen habe. Also das zog sich alles zusammen und,
und also ganz, ganz heftige, krampfartige Schmerzen, würde ich sagen. Und ja, und das strahlt
auch so ein bisschen aus hier hoch. Also ja, bis in den Rücken hoch eigentlich.
Frau Müller, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalapur,
nur bis 10, wobei nur keine Schmerzen 10 am starksten Schmerzen bedeutet?
Also über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle, ich würde sagen, mit so bei 7 oder so,
ich habe dann Buskupanzhäpfchen genommen und das hat so ein klein bisschen geholfen.
Vielleicht bin ich dann auch in der Nacht mal irgendwann ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Man
denkt ja immer, man schläft gar nicht, wenn man so eine schlechte Nacht hat. Und ja,
dann war es ein bisschen besser, aber heute Morgen ist es auch wieder jetzt ganz heftig.
Ja. Okay. Trätten die Schmerzen plötzlich oder
unmännlich auf? Nein, das ist ziemlich plötzlich gekommen nach dem ersten Jahr.
Und schlecht ist mir. Also jetzt immer noch. Ich habe mich auch einmal gegeben in der Nacht
und jetzt ist mir immer noch so wirklich sehr sehr übel. Okay. Trätten die Schmerzen anfassen
sich auf oder sind sie dauerhaft gohandeln? Benim Internetim Gitt?
Ist die Schmerz.
Benim Internetim Gellio?
Gellio, ja.
Frau Gerildin Internetim Gitt, o zaman.
Können Sie mich jetzt wieder hören?
Ja.
Okay. Also die Schmerzen sind plötzlich gekommen. Ja. Und wurden ein bisschen besser durch das
Zäpfchen und als ich dann ein Bett gelegen habe und so und auch nachdem ich mich übergeben
habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, ja, es geht mir irgendwie ein bisschen besser. Aber ja,
dann fing das wieder an, dass es mir so schlecht war und dass ich solche heftigen
Bauchschmerzen hatte. Und ja, also auch hier oben, das ist ganz und auch weil das so
in den Rückungsstrahl ist es ganz unangenehm.
Okay. Haben Sie gestern, was haben Sie gestern gegessen?
Ja, wir hatten ja so ziemlich, ziemlich fett gebratenen Fisch und mit so einer Panade
und wir hatten dann auch noch Kartoffelsalat und Mayonnaise dazu. Vielleicht war das ein
bisschen viel, ja.
Ja, wirklich.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich tatsächlich schon so ein bisschen heiß am
Kopf, ja.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Naja, also im Bett habe ich ja gerade gesagt, es ist ein bisschen besser geworden
und auch nachdem ich das Zäpfchen genommen habe, nur dieses Puskopanzäpfchen,
das hat schon ein bisschen geholfen, ja. Aber ja, mehr habe ich auch nicht
gemacht. Ich war auch total schlapp, weil mir so schlecht war, ja.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Heute dürfen Sie mich nicht nach Appetit tragen, aber normalerweise ist der ja
eigentlich nicht so schlecht, aber heute darf ich an Essen nicht mal denken, ja.
Und leiden Sie Übelkeit unter Übelkeit?
Habe ich doch gerade gesagt, dass mir so schlecht ist, ja. Ich habe mich auch einmal
übergeben, habe ich auch gesagt.
Einmal übergeben. Wie sah Ihre Erbruchene aus?
Das waren halt Reste von dem Essen, da war ich froh, dass es draußen war, ja.
Haben Sie ernliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, also ich erinnere mich, dass ich das schon mal gehabt habe,
nach so einem üppigen Kaffee trinken mit Sahnetorte, ja.
Also ja, fettig und süß irgendwie, das war glaube ich nicht so gut.
Und ja, also wenn ich so fett gebratene Sachen esse oder Pommes oder so was,
dann geht es mir schon mal ein bisschen schlechter, aber es schmeckt mir halt so gut, ne.
Und wann haben Sie ernliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Das ist schon ein paar Wochen her.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Normalerweise nicht, würde ich sagen, ne.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Na ja, also das, was ich tatsächlich habe, das sind sehr unangenehme Migräneattacken, ja.
Ja, das setzt mich dann völlig außer Gefecht, ja.
Und ja, ob man das so als Krankheit geswerten kann, weiß ich nicht.
Also mein Haus, das habe ich gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Und dann nehme ich aber auch schon Medikamente, ja.
Das hat man vor ein paar Jahren mal festgestellt und ja, eigentlich denke ich,
das ist so jung für so eine Sache, so dass man ständig Tabletten nimmt, aber ja, also,
ist ja auch wichtig, dass diese Fettwerte ein bisschen runtergehen, ja.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Dann nehme ich Simvastatin.
Simvastatin, wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine, das sind 20er, kann das sein?
Ich meine, Simvastatin, 20 und die nehmen mich halt am Abend ein.
Nur am Abend, richtig?
Einmal am Abend, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen, ja, in der Kindheit habe ich mal den Winter rausbekommen, ja.
Okay.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Wie alt muss ich da gewählen?
Vielleicht so 13, 12, 13, sowas in dem Drehen?
Du hast Komplikation?
Nee, das ist ja ein kleiner Eingriff, also das ist ganz gut gelaufen, ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Und sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Ich wüsste eigentlich nicht, dass ich Ihnen irgendein Mal allergisch bin.
Also, so viel ich weiß, kann ich alles vertragen.
Also kann alles essen.
Ich habe nicht irgendwie so Hautreaktionen.
Ja, also manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen Probleme, wenn ich so...
Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Gegen braunes Pflaster.
Gegen braunes Pflaster? Wie äußert sie ich?
Ja, also, da gibt es halt so kleine rote Flecken und ein jucktes ein bisschen,
also ist nichts Aufregendes.
Okay, rauchen Sie Frau Müller?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay, Sie schützen Ihre Gesundheit, indem Sie nicht rauchen.
Ja.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder, also einen Laster muss man ja haben.
Hin und wieder trinke ich gerne mal ein Glas Wein, ja.
Aber wirklich, wenn das einmal in der Woche ist
oder zweimal in der Woche, dann ist es viel.
Und bitte nehmen Sie nicht dafür nicht, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen ein?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts zu tun.
Hatt ich noch nie und habe ich auch nicht vor.
Okay, gut.
Und dient Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern.
Ja.
Mein Vater, mein Vater ist früh gestorben.
Der hatte Leberkrebs.
Und meine Mutter, ja, die lebt noch.
Nebt noch.
Und hat Ihre Mutter eine Erklärung?
Ja, das, was alle in dem Alter haben, die hat ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck
und sie hat halt so diesen Alterszucker.
Okay, da fang mir Leid.
Und mein Herz, ich schiss meine Leid für Ihre Vater.
Und habe Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und habe Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, die halten mich auf Trabjahr.
Ja.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind zum Glück gesund, ja.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Büroangestellte.
Und treiben Sie?
Ich muss auch viel Bildschirmen arbeiten.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, kann man schon sagen.
Das war mal in der Woche, gehe ich walken.
Und sonst fahre ich eigentlich ziemlich viel mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja, Frau Müller, das waren meine Fragen.
Ich habe alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Nach dem Angaben denke ich,
am ersten eine Gallenwege Stein.
Das ist nur ein Verdacht.
Und muss durch weitere Untersuchungen bestätigt werden.
Für diese Beschwerden müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Muss ich dazu näher bleiben?
Ja, für weitere Untersuchungen und zur Behandlung.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und jetzt würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ihre Bauch abtasten und Ihre Bauch abhören.
Dann würde ich Ihre Vitalparameter messen,
wie Herzfrequenz, Blutdruck, Blutzucker oder Sauerstoffsetigung.
Ja, aber ich liebe, ja, das sehen Sie, ja, dass ich ganz vital bin.
Ja.
Dann würde ich etwas Blut abnehmen,
um dabo chemische Untersuchungen bestimmen zu lassen.
Und eine EKG ist wichtig, eine kardiale Ursache ausschließen.
Ja, gegebenenfalls würde ich Bauchsonografie planen.
Eine Bauch, was?
Bauchsonografie.
Eine Sonografie? Ah, ja, okay.
Ja.
Und CT, Bauch CT würde ich anfertigen,
um in eine Organe sich bald zu machen.
Okay, ja, gut.
Darf ich Sie fragen?
Ja, eigentlich ist das schon klar.
Ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht,
dass ich tatsächlich hier bleiben muss,
aber vielleicht ist das besser,
denn mir geht es schon nicht so sehr gut, ja.
Okay.
Da muss ich nur zu Hause anrufen,
dass die irgendwie das klären,
dass alle versorgt sind, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Okay.
Sie können, Sie warten.
Ja, okay, dann setze ich mich ins Wartezimmer jetzt.
Hat jemand noch zusätzlich hier Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Was ist das für Sie,
wenn Sie fieber, nachtsschweiß oder schüttelfrost bemerken?
Nee, also mir war so ein bisschen warm in der Nacht, ja.
Aber, also, dass ich jetzt so schweißgebadet aufgewacht bin
oder so, dass ich nicht.
Und schüttelfrost hatte ich auch nicht, nee.
Ja, okay. Bleiben Sie eine Schlafstörung gut?
Normalerweise nicht, aber wie jetzt heute Nacht
habe ich, wie gesagt, wegen der Schmerzen nicht gut geschlafen.
Ja, okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Hab ich eigentlich auch schon gesagt, ich habe schon gesagt,
dass ich eigentlich ganz gerne esse, aber jetzt diese Tage,
also jetzt heute, ja, mag ich also nicht als Essen denken.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie ihn jetzt seit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Nee, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich ziemlich stabil, würde ich sagen.
Ja, leider, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Doch eine Frage.
Nee, doch nicht.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie soweit sind, ne?
Ich muss gerne, ja.
Okay. Hallo, guten Tag.
Demin ist mein Name.
Ich bin der neue Assistent.
Und möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin in der Nutzaufnahme vorstellen.
Oh ja, wie haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, es handelt sich um Frau Hanna Müller,
ein 42-jähriger, jähriger Patientin, geboren am 21.07.1983.
Sie ist 1 Meter 69 groß und sie wiegt aktuell 86 kg.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns mit seit gestern bestehenden,
gestern Abend bestehenden, löslich auftretenen,
progradieren, persistieren Oberbauchschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in der Rücken aus.
Sie beschreibt die Schmerzen als krankfartig.
Auserden berichtete sie die Schmerzen.
Auserden berichtete sie, dass sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala
mit 7 und 10 einstuft.
Okay.
Die Frage nach Auflöser wurde mit fettliches Essen bejaht.
Gestern hat sie fettgebrachte Fisch, Kartoffelsalat und Mayonnaise gegessen.
Sie hat Buscopan eingenommen.
Buscopan hat ein bisschen geholfen.
Was hat sie genommen?
Buscopan.
Buscopan, ja, dann ist gut.
Die Vegardate für Anamnese sind in Somni in Appä-Tanz auffällig.
Ähnliche Beschwerden sind vor ein paar Wochen aufgetreten.
Gab es auch einen Auslöser?
Ja, habe ich gesagt, fettliche.
Damals, vor einigen Wochen, gab es auch einen Auslöser.
Kaffee trinken.
Und als chronische Erkrankung wurde Migräne und Supercholesterolemie erwähnt.
Sie nehmen 20 mg Zimvastatin abends ein.
Sie sind allergisch gegen braunes Pflaster.
Wie ist allergisch?
Braunes Pflaster usert sich für Prämie.
Hautrüthung.
Ja, und sie rauchten die Frage nach, rauchen und trugen, wurde verneint.
Sie trinken ein Glas Wein, einmal oder zweimal in der Woche.
Ihr Vater ist gestorben an Leberkrebs.
Ihr Mutter leidet an Arterielle Hybetonie.
Sie ist ein Kind.
Sie ist verreiratet und zwei Kinder sind gesund.
Sie arbeitet im Büro.
Was ist jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Die an amnestischen Angaben deuten,
die Diagnose ist auf eine Polylithiasis.
Differenzialdiagnose ist auf Akutgas-Pangratitis.
Dann hätte sie durchfallen.
Was machen Sie mit der Diagnose?
Ich würde als erste Massnahme eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung erwarte ich Murphyzeiten.
Und Druckempfindlichkeit.
Worauf schauen Sie noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich würde mich abwärtsspannen.
Ich würde mit der Parameter messen.
Ja, Haulfarbe.
Ich würde eine EKG schreiben.
Ich würde eine kardiale Aussage auszuschließen.
Ich würde etwas Blut abnehmen.
Und eine labosche MS-Untersuchung festimmen.
Was würden Sie im Einzelnen bestimmen?
Großblutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte,
Colestaswerte, Pancreaswerte, wie Amilazipas.
Elektrolyte, Blutzucker.
Ja, okay.
Wie geht es weiter, wenn Sie Blut abgenommen haben?
Als separativer Untersuchung werde ich eine Bauchsonografie durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ich habe eine Vergrößerte, Gallenwege.
Erweiterte, ich glaube, eine.
Steine erwarte ich.
Flüssigkeitsamsamlung in Abdomen.
Ja, das war es.
Wie wäre denn in dem Fall, dass Ihre Diagnose zutrifft?
Was wäre dann das Behandlungsschema?
Wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt wird, würde ich ...
würde ich eine symptomatische Therapie einleiten, wie Analgetika, Antimethika.
Und ich würde Flüssigkeitssupur mit Elektrolyte beginnen.
Und zusätzlich würde ich ein gastroenterologisches Konsul antworten.
Okay, ja.
Und ein Polycystekdomi planen.
Gut.
Ja, wunderbar. Sehr gut.
Sie haben natürlich richtig gelegen.
Das ist tatsächlich ein geilen Problem gewesen.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen sehr ähnlich zu Ihrer Nefritis-Neulich-Böle.
Die Problematik, aber die Seite war eine andere.
Ja, na gut.
Aber sie haben sich gut geschlagen.
Eine Sache hat mir so ein bisschen gefehlt.
Das war die Verwendung von Fachbegriffen.
Also würde man eigentlich schon erwarten, dass man sagt,
diese akuten Schmerzen in Postprandial aufgetreten.
Ja, echt?
Ja, das ist ja immer so ein bisschen blöff auch,
dass man die Fachbegriffe auch tatsächlich verwendet.
Gut.
Was Sie nicht gefragt haben,
ist vielleicht nicht so relevant in diesem Zusammenhang.
Aber sollte man sicherlich immer noch wieder auf dem Schirm haben,
Reise an einem Nese und Impfungen.
Ja.
Haben Sie nicht nachgefragt?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie jetzt im Augenblick der aktuelle Stand
der Dinge ist in den Kliniken.
Wie weit da immer noch auch nach Covid-Impfung abgefragt wird.
Ich kann es gar nicht sagen.
Aber ich denke mal schon, dass das sinnvoll ist in jedem Fall,
das auf alle Fälle noch mit zu fragen.
Dann habe ich vielleicht ein kleines, sprachliches Missverständnis.
Ich meine, KFT macht, glaube ich, auch etwas bei garlen Leuten.
Das kriegen die auch Beschwerden von.
Aber sie hat ja gesagt, sie nach einem Kaffee trinken
mit Sahnetorte, also auch wieder fett als Auslöser.
Ja?
Ich habe gesagt, mit Tote.
Die Torte habe ich nicht gehört.
Ah, ich habe gesagt.
Gut.
Ja, die Torte hatte ich tatsächlich akustisch nicht vernommen.
Aber dann ist es okay.
Und dann hatte ich tatsächlich zu dem Gesamtbild
einen Kaffee trinken mit Sahnetorte, genau.
Und danach hatte sie halt auch schon einmal Bauchschmerzen,
aber eben nicht so heftig wie jetzt.
Genau.
Ja, das war, also ich fand einmal, war sie sehr zügig.
Und haben das wirklich flink durchgemacht.
Sie haben die diagnostischen Schritte eigentlich auch schön beschrieben.
Und auch nachher die Therapie.
Was sie, glaube ich, im Arztgespräch nicht erwähnt haben,
das war die Abnytdektomie.
Und sie haben, glaube ich, auch nicht nachgefragt,
ob die irgendwelche Medikamente gegen die Migräne nimmt.
Sie haben nur das Statin.
Das sind was Statin für die Colesterolinwerte genommen
oder angegeben.
Aber sie nimmt eben auch noch das Migräne-Medikament.
Und da haben sie aber gar nicht weiter nachgefragt.
Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, haben sie sich auch sprachlich
ziemlich gut geschlagen.
Ich glaube, die meisten Missverständnisse hatten wir jetzt
durch technische Probleme, dass sie mich nicht gut verstehen konnten
aufgrund der Internetverbindung.
War das jetzt im zweiten Anlauf denn besser oder war immer noch
so schlecht? War besser oder immer noch fehlerhaft?
Ja, jetzt ist besser besser.
Jetzt konnten Sie mich verstehen.
Okay.
Was ich vielleicht noch reklamieren würde, ist einmal die Sache,
rücken Sie doch nicht leicht mit der Diagnose raus,
dem Patienten gegenüber.
Halten Sie sich bedeckt und lassen Sie Ihre Vermutung
erst mal bei sich und sagen Sie das nachher dem
ärztlichen Kollegen, aber nicht dem Patienten gegenüber.
Find ich persönlich strategisch besser.
Man kann sagen, ja, ich vermute, da ist was an der Gallenblase.
Aber, ah ja, fällt mir dabei gerade ein.
Da gibt es diese schöne Regel.
Welche Risikofaktionen gibt es für die Gallenblase?
Für die Gallenerkrankung?
6F. Ja, genau.
Family 40, also.
Ja, passt rein, ja.
Ja, FET, Adopositas, ja, Fairly.
Und Family, Weitlichstichness.
Und Schwangerschaft.
Ja, genau.
Ich denke, das ist so eine klassische Frage.
Benim Internet, mein Internet.
Das war das eine, also Diagnose,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt gleich den Patienten gegenüber.
Und ja, also wenn das mit dem verstorbenen Vater,
wenn das ja nicht brandaktuell war, ja, das ist jetzt gerade eben,
wenn die Patientin sagt, ja, letzte Woche ist mein Vater gestorben,
dann finde ich das schon auch okay, oh mein Beileid, ja.
Aber wenn das schon länger zurück ist,
würde ich das tatsächlich auch übergehen, ja.
Und ja.
Ja, auch da haben Sie, wie gesagt,
es an Leberkrebs gestorben.
Auch da kann man natürlich den Fachterminus benutzen.
Hepatocellurcardus.
Bitte?
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, im Patientengespräch,
ja immer die deutschen Begriffe und im Arztgespräch,
gerne die Fachterminologie,
damit die Kollegen sehen auch das beherrschte Prüfling.
Ja, gut, aber ich denke, das ist sehr, sehr gut gelaufen.
Helfen Sie mir nochmal wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, ich habe 5. Mai nicht bestanden, in 5. Mai nicht bestanden.
Ich habe einmal abgedacht.
Ja, aber haben Sie schon den nächsten Termin?
25. September.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, diesmal müsste es klappen.
Also das müsste mit dem Dorbel zugehen.
Ja, also ich fand es jetzt wirklich ziemlich gut, muss ich sagen.
Ja.
Und ja, seien Sie entspannt.
Gut.
Ansonsten, ja, haben wir es für heute geschafft.
Es ging relativ fix,
weil jetzt auch nicht so ein ganz wahnsinnig umfangreicher Fall.
Durch der Vorteil, wenn Patienten jung sind,
haben die noch nicht so eine riesig lange Krankengeschichte vorne weg.
Ja, die, wir können uns am Dienstag treffen.